The initial value for the velocity of the car is of course 120 km/h converted to m/s
and the initial value for the velocity of the rim of the wheel
has to equal the velocity of the car so that there is no slip.
The implementation of the forward Euler method should be straightforward.
The top most subplot illustrates the braking distance.
The endpoint of each these curves is at the braking distance.
The second subplot shows that the car velocity decreases almost linearly.
This is not quite sure of the wheel velocity.
In particular, you can see that the rear velocity
quickly deceases to zero when the strength of braking this too high.
The most interesting part, however, is the lower subplot. It shows the wheel slip.
If we apply just a little of braking, we're going to run into the lower equilibrium, which is a stable one
and which is always below the optimum value of the wheel slip of 0.2,
and to see that for this curve colored in green and this curve colored in purple,
we do not reach such a reasonable equilibrium, however, the wheel locks up.
The wheel slip becomes one, which we have seen in the plot above as well.
Among these five options, the red one seems to work best and you see that we must not apply
too little braking and that we must not apply too much braking.
You maybe wondering about this artifact here. Remember how we compute the wheel slips.
One minus the velocity of the rim of the wheel divided by the velocity the car.
If these two gets close to zero, the ratio is going to vary widely.
This is a numerical artifact. So the reason for this artifact is built into our equations.
At the end of the simulation, we're dividing numbers, which are close to zero.
That's always a bad idea when it comes to maintaining stability.